so
Andrew he knows that I'm a man of Faith
like I was born and raised like a
Christian it was video that went viral
oh yeah
ran by the deaf uh the to draw if you
want to call that like what what do you
call it shaytan but you see them acting
as if they're women uh different things
like that with uh Tristan Tate and also
with Andrew Tate there and I was talking
to Andrew and Andrew's like Dylan why
don't you just live here didn't put this
out publicly but I actually went out I
went to a mosque about a month ago with
a friend for the first time breaking
down how Islam is like almost the
perfect path and I remember for a split
second feeling like
what's going on like almost right across
the street was a mosque and every day I
would see it be like I want to go over
there but I'm not sure but I there might
be something more to this uh this Islam
thing now I mean that aligns with my
beliefs 100 yeah you're a Muslim brother
I mean you're Muslim I mean that's it
[Music]
we're here with uh
yes yeah all right guys so we signed
everything here
yeah
Next Step you gotta get the keys now
[Music]
hello
[Applause]
[Music]
Muslims around here it's it's pretty
huge and uh like this the place the
location that you opened in basically
it's far further south from the other
other big massages and everyone I know a
lot of people but I used to I come my
cousin lives nine minutes from here
another Uncle of mine lives about five
to ten minutes from here this area
opened up in an area that it's much
needed and this size yeah I mean this
the center this Center is much needed
for this area and the idea of this
Center is needed for the whole stick
because we don't have anything like that
in the whole state that was sensor where
it's gonna basically nurture and
basically educate and it's gonna
basically spread Islam
is
a piece how are you guys doing my next
guest
is tweeted recently
holding a copy of the Quran and asking
us a question and it's interesting
because this copy that
I'm very well familiar with it's a
previous guest that I had on the program
Dr Mustafa
so we reached out to Dylan Madden to get
more of a background of how he got a
copy of this Quran
the clear Quran and also he's also been
following this case with our brother
Andrew Tate so we'll get to the bottom
of some new developing evidence that's
been coming out let's uh waste no time
and bring out Dylan Madden
and his final message
[Music]
the theme show
how are you doing Dylan do a fantastic
thank you so much for having me it's an
honor thank you thank you for being uh
accept an invitation to be on the
program
yeah so you're uh you're in Dubai
yeah I moved here back in December I got
here and I because I was originally in
Paraguay so down in South America and I
was talking to Andrew and Andrew's like
Dylan why don't you just live here and I
was making my way back to the hotel and
I was like why don't I live here so
everything else worked out I ended up
setting up residency it was a pretty
straightforward process and I lived in
Qatar previously for about nine months
which kind of connects with I guess
today's topic as well kind of opened my
mind to a few different things
especially being from America originally
so I already liked the overall culture
so for me I feel at home here in Dubai
tell me so you recently tweeted
and you were showing this picture of the
Quran
and you were asking people
where should you start to read how did
you get a hold of the Quran uh tell us a
little background to this so
Andrew he knows that I'm a man of Faith
like I was born and raised like a
Christian so I I've always had a love uh
respect for God and all of that and I've
went I've dabbled I was funny uh before
I got off on a tangent I actually read
the Quran for the first time back
whatever I was like 13. in a library in
school and the teachers or not the
teacher the librarian it's like oh why
are you reading that it's her question
me and I was like oh I guess it's bad so
I put it back but it's always kind of
been in the back of my mind and before
Andrew left he gave me a copy of the
Quran and I haven't read this book yet
but he also said he recommends and I
read this so can you hold that up closer
what is that
and raising the mail into secret men
okay and then can you put can you put
the other ones you can show the yes this
one here yes okay so this is clear Quran
from the uh Dr Mustafa yes that's
interesting this reminded me also
because uh in my interaction with uh
Andrew Tate if my if my memory serves me
well I sent him there is actually a
website clearquran.com by the also the
author who made it and I believe I sent
this to Andrew when um after we had our
first interview yeah that's interesting
yeah that's awesome because he gave he
was about to deport from Dubai back
before or right before all that stuff
happened and it's like
you don't have to but I recommend you
read this and he gave me a copy of the
Quran he gave me the other book and kind
of just sat in my desk and I've just
been thinking and thinking and I I
didn't put this out publicly but I
actually went out I went to a mosque
about a month ago with a friend for the
first time so I know this sounds
ignorant or whatever but like I was kind
of nervous I was like should I should I
go like What's it gonna be like and a
friend of mine was like let's go now so
we ended up uh what is it called Isha I
don't know it's the the latest you got
it right yeah Isha prayer that's the
last prayer yeah beautiful so yeah we
did that and then I actually went to the
mosque yesterday with I think they're
called the three brother podcast oh yeah
okay yeah yeah and then another guy uh
oh man I'll have to look at his
Instagram but anyways he basically lives
in Los Angeles and approaches people in
the street and talks to them about Chris
about Islam and uh Jewels uh who might
be coming on the show at some point he
he knows about you as well whenever I
say yeah I'm gonna go with the dean show
usually brother that is that was so
awesome that like congratulations so we
all went to the mosque last night and we
did our own prayer originally and then
we also did the last prayer uh right I
guess the last prayer of the day as well
and then I ended up coming back home
after that so yeah I mean that's why
I've always wanted answered that's
pretty cool so you got you got some you
uh spent some time with the brothers
with uh Tristan Tate and also with
Andrew Tate there and in your course of
spending some time with uh them Andrew
actually gave you gifted was this this
is uh after he accepted Islam yeah this
was after he had accepted yeah yeah so
what's your experience been now so it
reminds me of a authentic statement from
the prophet Muhammad peace and blessings
be upon him who obviously by now you
know we believe he was the last
messenger sent from Mankind in the line
of Messengers and they all brought the
same message which is Islam to submit
your will to the creator of heavens and
earth so it reminds me of the statement
that he said for the one who takes one
step to God to Allah Allah will take 10
towards him so I'm just seeing all this
you know it's like you're taking that
step in it you're you're getting to
start to meet all these different people
and it's like uh God Almighty Allah is
is guiding you along the way slowly but
surely what do you think is that does uh
from your experience now with all these
different Muslims and with all the hype
that's out there you know you're brave
enough you know to step into a mosque
and you know coming from from this side
of the world a lot of people are like
you were saying a little apprehensive
they're scared because all the media you
know the bad press the stereotypes
yeah brother I mean for me back whenever
I came to Dubai back in 2019 I was at
the mall of Dubai and the call to
worship came on and I remember for a
split second feeling like
what's going on like almost like a fear
and my friend looked at me and he was
like yeah let's get out of here so we
left uh but then funnily enough random
circumstances happen because I like to
travel the world and right before all
the stuff happened over the previous
couple years with a certain thing
floating around if you get my drift yeah
I ended up in Qatar and I was only
supposed to be there for about two to
three weeks uh just getting some work
done and they ended up closing the
borders and I ended up getting an
apartment there because they just kept
renewing the Visa and right across the
street was a mosque and every day I
would see it be like I want to go over
there but I'm not sure but it actually
gave me a sense of Peace hearing the
cult of worship and then seeing the
dedication of people coming and I know
this is kind of off topic but I was
sitting down with all the the gentleman
yesterday we were talking and they were
basically breaking down how Islam is
like almost the perfect path the perfect
guide for men today to like become their
best self because like why do why do you
need all these extra sources of power
when you can literally
directly be blessed by Allah or God or
whatever you call it so it's that for me
it's I'm still in the learning phase
like I have not converted I still have
some apprehensions as well since I was
born and raised as a Christian but I
could feel myself being guided uh step
by step if that makes sense yeah we just
talked about that step by step you're
taking one step and now if a person is
sincere and I always tell people this is
the simple homework just keep asking the
creator of the heavens and the Earth
alone for the guidance Guide Me Guide Me
Guide Me you know what I mean that's
very simple God Almighty Allah will
facilitate uh away as he's doing you can
see and then the the message is is a
believable message it's easy to
understand it's based around that pure
monotheism a worshiping God Almighty
alone and not his creation and uh how
was it when you walked into a to a
Masjid a mosque I mean
when you go into other places of worship
what people have expressed is they go in
there they see all these different
statues icons Idols you know they go
into Hamas for the first time there's
none of these there's nothing you know
it's peace Serenity and they're just
there they're watching people pray like
I mean as a Christian coming from a
Christian background you see how in the
Bible it describes the prophets and even
Jesus praying by falling on his face
praying to God and this is what you're
seeing Andrew Tate was with uh Tam Khan
when he was praying you know that famous
video that went viral yeah
[Music]
yeah and then also when you went into
the mosque how is it just seeing this
now now you're in there you're brave
enough you come in first year a little
apprehensive now you go in there what's
the feeling like you know what are you
observing let people who've never people
who are now on this side of the world
they're like okay what'd you see in
there right what's going on
so for me personally I I like this
actually I observed this last night the
one thing I really appreciated is
whenever I went in people could tell
that I didn't know what I was doing but
everybody kept like oh yeah just you
don't have to say anything no pressure
just kind of follow along so like I
would go like this and put my hand down
on my knees and then we like would go
through the whole process and it's it's
just beautiful you feel a sense of Peace
like there's no tension there's none of
that that was actually something that
bothered me for me I was baptized as a
Baptist so we didn't necessarily we
didn't have like the crucifixes and all
that with like somebody bleeding on the
cross but something that has always
bothered me about Christianity uh just
at a personal level is how it's almost
as if you're you're praying to an idol
up on like a statue that isn't it
doesn't even look like what Jesus would
have looked like uh or you're eating the
flesh drinking the blood during like
communion like little things like that
has always always kind of bothers me uh
but then compare that to the mosque it's
like sure some of them are fancy inside
but it's all about just worshiping God
that's it uh so it's it's once again
it's still new to all this but that's
that's so far been my observation
I mean you're not the only one this is
something that all of us are born with
we have this innate disposition
to connect with the truth when it comes
and also the main truth is who who is
your creator who is God you know is it
the human being is it the ancient
ancestors is it my ideas and Islam makes
that clear that uh the clear description
of who God is is very very
straightforward and I want to share this
uh with you straight from the Quran you
know this is a chapter you had that
question which which one should I where
should I start reading this is a very
powerful verse that helps the human
being God Almighty is describing who he
is and who he isn't in in this chapter
in the Quran
let's stop right there so do you see
that first verse what God Almighty is
saying about himself this is interesting
um Dylan that you know if I told you if
I said look tell so and so you know to
come here you know the Quran is verbatim
you know why it's being passed along to
prop from Angel Gabriel the prophet
Muhammad and he's saying say cool
and that's even transmitted here if you
notice it's just small detail so he's
saying say and this is coming to us
nothing is left out whatever was given
through uh Angel Gabriel to Prophet
Muhammad it we have it today preserved
authentically over a span of 23 years
compiled and now we have the Quran the
English translation is the meaning the
original is in the Arabic up above here
so say he is Allah the one
you cannot add three to it make it into
one you can't edit that it's just purely
one and this is just sober that's the
pure monotheism and then we go to the
second chapter he's a lot the
Eternal so he doesn't sleep he doesn't
rest he on the seventh day no this is
does that so far make sense oh yeah it
totally does you know I mean it just
totally makes sense you know what I mean
then you keep going here uh he doesn't
uh he neither begets nor is he born so
God Almighty doesn't have children like
you uh me you know we're human beings
you know cows have calves uh cats have
kittens right uh what does God have a
baby God like that doesn't make no sense
you know so here God is Almighty is
saying that no he doesn't have children
he's not born of anyone and there is
nothing comparable to him nothing you
can imagine fathom is God and going back
to what you were saying
going into uh something that you had a a
problem with and and that is you know
God Almighty in certain churches you'll
have blue uh eyed blonde hair you go to
another place they have Jesus you go to
China you have Chinese Jesus you know
you never sat well with me it doesn't
set well with a lot of people thinking
people and here Islam just gets rid of
all that no God doesn't have a zip code
an area code of color he's not a human
being he's not his creation but he
created creation makes sense right so
you're not in your head because that's
that's the truth and it resonates so
you're there you're there I say if you
can dig this you can dig Islam
everything else will come easy and then
it's just accepting Prophet Muhammad as
the final messenger and this would
include all the preceding Messengers I
mean Jesus Moses Abraham and they all
came in the same message calling
Humanity to serve and worship the one
God and to stay away from worshiping his
creation to be morally upright that's it
what do you think about that
well I definitely I'm open to it yeah so
continue so continue on now so you go
your your uh meeting some of the the
Muslims there how else has your your
experience been what else uh what what
are some of these apprehensions besides
the one you mentioned that you're having
yeah I mean from a positive standpoint
the the thing I really like about is
just the Brotherhood aspect uh like you
can tell it's all genuine it's all real
uh for me personally and actually
something you just said from an
apprehension standpoint is
could you explain a little bit more
about how the message came through an
angel which then went to Muhammad
yeah so this is this has been the
throughout time so Prophet Muhammad used
to go to meditate he used to go and he
was in an environment where they had 360
Idols you know and they were worshiping
the creation they were worshiping idols
and they believed in Allah they believed
in the crater but they would go through
intermediaries and whatnot so he was
away from this right he would go into
the the mountain and reflect and then
you had Angel Gabriel who's also
mentioned this is also an angel who was
mentioned uh in the Bible is there and
this angel came and from there it's real
it's meticulously preserved everything
you know how the incident happened you
know what happened from there you know
how he went to his wife and you know and
then how he went to his community after
that and he stood in front of a on top
of a mountain that they would go ahead
and if there was any news because
obviously he didn't have TVs and radio
back then so he went from there there he
went on to the mountain you know to call
the people there's a big announcement
everybody's running to come and he said
look if I told you that there was an
Army coming
that they were about to attack would you
believe me and they said of course we
known you never telling a lie he wasn't
look uh do you have a do you have a
nickname that people call you by
yourself
I mean all my friends call me money back
Madden okay money money back matter okay
so you know people give each other
nicknames right uh well his nickname was
El Amin the trustworthy right never
known to have total lie come on so now
he's going to come up what's the motive
what's behind it so after this he came
out and he told them you know he
delivered the message and he warned them
of a punishment coming the Hellfire he
called them away from idolatry he called
him to what to the pure monotheism and
he called him to paradise and then
proofs of proofs were were established
you know the Quran is a living Miracle
during the time of Jesus Jesus came with
Miracles but you cannot now use that to
convince the atheists because he was at
a certain time sent for a certain people
so Muhammad being the last and final
messenger he had to come with evidences
and proofs and that's what we have today
this living living Miracle um and if you
examine for instance uh the Quran in
chapter 32 verse 2 talks about that the
Quran is it's in the Quran God was
saying God Almighty is saying that he's
the one that revealed the Quran and he's
the one that's going to preserve it you
have a challenge in the Quran if you
feel that this is from other then God
Almighty Allah come produce something
like it go ahead bring an individual
bring a group of people bring Humanity
all together try to produce something
like the Quran you know the
falsification test I'll give you one
example there was a man there who was an
enemy to Islam and then God Almighty
revealed the verse in there saying that
this person is condemned he's going to
be in the Hellfire so imagine that
all they had to do was come out and say
you know what I ex fake it he just could
have came out said I accepted Islam but
we know this person died as a non-muslim
there was 27 Wars they were fought they
could have won this intellectually and
put it all all to rest the prophecies
that are in the Quran you know they're
substantiated
um you have 500 plus scientific uh facts
signs Miracles that we'd say you know
and the human development How the
Universe began if you were to go ahead
and take for instance every time there
was something accurate you would put it
on the right side here uh and on the
left side you would put things say the
green is for accurate the red is for
inaccuracies and every time there's
something accurate that we can go ahead
substantiate we say okay he got it right
here you'd be like okay put a green one
here wrong put it here but there is none
that's going the right in the red side
there's none that's the thing that uh
blew my mind away
and from there the believable message
the prophet Muhammad when you look at
his life and I don't want to go I could
just keep going but I want to give you a
chance to respond uh to this uh because
there's just so many pro it's not Blind
Faith Dylan that's the the thing I want
to stress there's so much overwhelming
evidence from looking at his life to
evaluating the Quran you know the
believable message not calling you to
believe in something that your innate
nature Rejects at the end of the day
you're just like man I gotta submit here
otherwise what else do I have you know
what I mean this is uh this is the truth
yeah so like I I know from what I was
told yesterday and I I've already was
aware of this because I've done a little
bit of studying it seems that uh how do
you pronounce it
yes sir I sir
Jesus yeah yeah he is heavily respected
I mean what was the whole purpose of him
then coming into the world because I
supposedly he's a he's very revered and
respected yes Jesus you're talking about
Jesus you know it's an Article of Faith
to believe in love Jesus in Islam you
cannot say any disrespectful word about
him or his Blessed Mother there's a
whole chapter named after his mother in
the Quran and he came as a messenger
because the people the children of
Israel at that time they went astray
so he came just like we believe over a
hundred twenty four thousand Prophets
were sent to humanity and some of them
we know by name many of them we don't
just to name a few you have uh Adam the
first man for instance he was the first
Muslim he was told to submit his will to
the Creator to God Almighty Allah and he
did that's what a Muslim is simple so
when when we say Muslim that's not an
Arab in the desert you know that's uh
not whatever you think it is it's a is a
translation is what I just told you to a
person a peaceful person who submits his
or her to God so the first man Adam and
then from there you had Noah and uh from
there you had all the different
Messengers we'll put up here so people
can kind of get an idea here on the side
and that just kept going so people they
went off and they started some people
went and they obeyed they they accepted
the call
and other people they went and they did
their own thing and that's how you had
man-made religions they started to come
up other people started to worship
creation other people worshiped their
desires stick stones and Bones etc etc
and that's how that's how man-made
religions get created so then when
people started to drift off God Almighty
would send another Messenger to warn the
people to call them back to the straight
path so people will accept some people
reject it's your free will it's your
choice and that's why there's the
Paradise in the Hellfire so those people
who live a morally upright life they
live according to the the laws that God
Almighty revealed the pure monotheism
God Almighty is the most merciful lover
you're going to make a mistake but you
don't need a blood sacrifice you don't
need somebody to come down and die for
your sins and Islam everyone is born on
original goodness not original sin so
that baby that's born it's like a a
clean sheet of paper now when you become
when you hit puberty around that's when
now your Deeds start getting recorded
but if you make a mistake you turn to
the all-loving the most merciful you
don't go to a confession box you don't
go into you know you hide your person
yeah so uh so go what do you think so
far that those are some of the the the
main the main um you know introductory
things that we like to explain to people
uh but Jesus but Jesus he was a mighty
messenger he came with the same messages
Moses Abraham Prophet Muhammad but then
he was restricted to that time period
and that's the main thing but now God
Almighty and his wisdom knew that we're
going to have internet today you know uh
there's a prophecy being fulfilled today
that Prophet Muhammad said that this
message will reach everything that comes
Under the Sun you know every home
whatever it's made out of you know that
it's going to reach and Islam is is
definitely reaching because of the
modern investment so Prophet Muhammad
being the last and final messenger uh
because God Almighty knew the times that
we'd be living at that time how would
that message reach us today right yeah
so that's uh how um I would go ahead and
just help you to understand
okay oh yeah I mean for me it's
I understand that there's evil in the
world I understand there's good in the
world and
something that I started catching my
attention probably about a year and a
half ago as I started noticing that it
seemed like
in the world like the online World
specifically Islam seems to be one of
the only like religions that actually is
able to penetrate and stand firm but
then you look at Christianity and you
see them I won't use certain keywords
but you see them acting as if they're
women uh different things like that
dressing up and just
as as I guess you would say Haram type
of outfits but yet they're preachers and
pastors and they're way too welcoming
there's nothing wrong with being
welcoming but I mean if if you're
actually if you've got a viable and if
you've got rules and all that you're
supposed to follow then why are you just
oh yeah it's okay we'll accept anybody
at little things like that sort of
bothering me uh and then I started
seeing your videos I started seeing some
other people's videos and that sort of
getting me I was like
started I mean when I say bother me not
in a negative way but like bothering me
a little bit as then I was like there
might be something more to this uh this
Islam thing
um I guess for me personally from a
Christian perspective we believe because
I've been talking to a lot of Muslims
here and we actually agree on most
things uh because they also like they've
a lot of them have read the Bible they
also respect Jesus different things like
that in my opinion it seems that what is
it the digital like in the Christianity
is the Antichrist the digital
it's like it seems like in today's world
we're more and more getting into
that Peak point where the digital is
like yeah I don't even need to name drop
anything but uh you you could look
around the world and you see it it's
just it's getting out of control and it
seems like in my opinion like
Christianity maybe Islam they seem to be
more like stronger on it from a social
media standpoint it seems like that's
really the only thing that can come in
and
not save the entire world but at least
save the world to a degree uh because
people nowadays especially in the west
as part of why I don't live in the U.S
and I I like to live in places actually
have morals such as the United Arab
Emirates Etc is
the West seems to be falling away and
it's
ran by the deaf uh the draw if you want
to call that like what what do you call
it shaytan is that how you pronounce it
shaytan yes that's the main the main
devil yes yeah just running it from
Hollywood and just the US is purporting
a lot of this stuff and I've often
wondered if that's maybe why a lot of
the propaganda like me
as a young American like I remember
seeing all this stuff being programmed
like every Muslim wants to like
basically cut your head off every Muslim
uh it will get rewarded if they kill you
or they'll go to paradise which maybe
for the viewers that might be something
helpful like what what's the truth
behind like if you kill uh Infidel like
what happens like as I was told
yesterday like you're not you're not
supposed to kill anything you're not
supposed to harm anything but like for
an American propaganda perspective I was
told like oh if you if you kill the
infidels you get 72 virgins and all this
other stuff yeah
[Music]
yeah so let me that's one of the
misconceptions and deliberate
attacks that you had many of the
orientalists and many of the haters of
Islam you know put out there this this
propaganda that's crazy this false fear
but you're a proof right now you've been
in Qatar uh where you also just had the
uh FIFA there the soccer
championships there and you had so many
people testifying coming out like man
it's great over here you are you saw
some of the footage coming out of there
right oh yeah uh but imagine before you
know people would see for themselves you
know they're stuck listening and hearing
what's going on and many people you know
uh Time Magazine did an article I
believe it was a night in the 1970s
discussing how many books I believe it
was something around 50 000 books that
you had like one book a day coming out
with this negative with lies distortions
about Islam so you could you can just
imagine what people are being fed but
now when they go to the sources when
they connect with Muslims and I'll just
give you an example look look at Prophet
Muhammad back to him his life you know
he had 30 assassination attempts on his
life can you imagine 30 assassination
attempts right he's still he still
survived all the way to the end until
the Quran was complete at any time if he
would have if he would have died we
wouldn't have the message today all the
way up until he got this
a verse revealed that Allah is saying
that he Allah will protect I will
protect you God Almighty is saying that
he will protect him so what happens is
then God in the beginning Prophet
Muhammad he had he has security
so he this this verse comes down and he
says you know he he pretty much gets rid
of the security and he survives all the
way to the end now what happens is
the Muslims are the early Muslims were
persecuted they were tortured I mean you
just can't uh fathom and imagine you
know all of the evil that was done and
then towards the end what happened was
you had the conquests of Mecca now
imagine if you watch some of these
movies that we watch in Hollywood and
you know when the when the persecuted
Army comes back right now nobody would
hold you to account if you had these
people who came and they they pillaged
and they raped and they did all sorts of
evil towards your family right now it's
time for Revenge right but when Prophet
Muhammad came back with an army of ten
thousand strong imagine it at ten
thousand strong what do you think he did
did he come in and and like the Crusades
and you had blood up into the to the to
the knees you know as they narrate did
he come and start cutting off heads
chopping off heads what did he do
he came in with his head low lowered
humble he didn't come in leap into doing
the Conor McGregor you know what I mean
like yeah no he came in he was humble
and he said what do you think I'll do to
you today
and they started to praise him and you
know and what did he do he saying you're
a good man you're this that now the tide
has turned he pre he freed the community
he said go ahead and he let them free
this is this is an example of Mercy
there was a few who were held account
you know there was a there was a few
but the majority everybody was free and
many of his enemies even Christians uh a
Christian scholar by the name of uh
warakai benofol you had a Jewish scholar
of the time Abdullah IBN Salam these
were the learning at the time they also
they accepted the message they were
looking for signs of a messenger to come
so I can go on and on you know there's a
chapter in the Quran it's very
straightforward on this chapter
um 60 talks about
um that for those who have not driven
you out of your homes who have not
fought you because of religion uh it's
for you to deal kindly and justly with
them so this whole thing you know that
people cut in Pace versus like you know
kill them wherever you find them in war
of course what are you going to say
we're going out into war and you're
going to say give you know give the guy
uh you know a high five I mean yeah that
is a fair point yeah so in war so this
is clear there are verses in there
that now establish how to go ahead and
act you know justly in war right you
cannot kill innocent men women and
children people in houses of worship
everything is just clearly laid out yeah
you know the rules of engagement that
they didn't even have in the Geneva
Convention you know you know Islam laid
all this clearly out but now when you're
in battle you have a right or if
somebody's coming to go ahead and attack
you and your family you have a right to
defend yourself and this is what those
verses that people take out kill this
this and that that's when the general is
telling the Army how to March forward
how to give you know the troops you know
that motivation and what to do and then
it becomes right so you're all ready to
go but otherwise if they want to extend
the hand towards peace you go towards
peace
I I like that I guess one other question
that just kind of popped to my head is
what's the significance about the the
cube in Mecca
that is that has always kind of bothered
me I've read some conspiracies I'd like
to hear yeah I mean this is what we say
the first house of worship this spot
built by Abraham to commemorate the
worship of one God then it was built
over time and that you can actually go
in there and you can pray
um you can go ahead inside the Kaaba so
it's a unification of the Muslim
Community praying in the same direction
unifying us and this is really simply
what um you know there's a lot more you
can go deeper into it but it's a
unification we all stand in prayer
towards the Kaaba but we're not praying
to it it's a unification of Direction
and it was the first house of worship
built by Abraham to commemorate the
worship of one and only one God
that's powerful what I want to share
with you is um is because there's so
many uh directions a person can go and
they can get lost you can spend a whole
lifetime studying studying Islam and a
better one came to Prophet Muhammad he
said look if I hold on to the monotheism
the shahada you know uh will lie because
this man is a nomad right he's busy with
all the different things you know that
he has to do to survive and he says look
if I if I hold on to x y z the Five
Pillars basically the prayer and uh yeah
right pretty much if I hold on to this
and he the prophet Muhammad said if this
man is truthful as he left he said he'll
be a man of paradise so Islam is simple
you know depending on your level where
you're at you know as long as you uh
believe in the six articles of faith has
anybody explained to you the six
articles of Faith so far not yet I'll go
it's very simple this is I don't we
don't have to I want to go into the the
case uh because you've been also talking
about the case so I want to just touch
upon this before we get into that these
developing
uh new evidences that come out that have
came out the media is just uh Community
silent on it's interesting but yeah you
have the six articles of Faith one is to
believe in one and only one God to
believe in the angels to believe in the
books that were revealed
uh for example what was given to dawu
David the sa of the um Sabor what was
given to Jesus uh dengia what was given
to Moses the Torah and what we have the
prophet Muhammad the last and final
revelation of mankind the Quran so
believe in the books uh to Believe In
The Messengers that were sent to believe
in the day a judge they have judgment
and predestiny so this is pretty much in
a nutshell the six articles of faith if
you believe this
then those are the beliefs in the heart
so there is there anything here that you
would reject that you feel like
questionable about from these beliefs
this is now the engine of Islam yeah I
mean it's pretty logical and uh they
they think it was called the five
pillars of Islam okay we'll get to that
now yes so if you believe if you tell me
right now say I believe in this I
believe in the one God I believe in the
angels I believe in the books The
Messengers the day of judgment and
predestiny
yeah you're a Muslim brother I mean
you're a Muslim I mean that's it now now
talk is cheap like yeah
you got to show it five pillars come
into play now you got to testify it now
you got to come out and say it now you
have to do it with your limbs what's the
first one is that you testified that
there's nothing worthy of worship come
out you already agree that there's uh
nothing worthy of worship except one and
only one God in Arabic we say Allah
and Muhammad is the messenger that's the
shahada that's that's what Andrew Tate
had to take to come into Islam and if
you were living during the time of Jesus
Jesus you would have said to shahada if
you were living the time of Moses you
would have said the shahada but at the
end you would say Moses is the messenger
at Jesus time you say Jesus is the
messenger you make sense yeah that makes
sense yeah yeah so it's all it's the
same thing and and and then you would
establish the prayer
then you establish the prayer five times
a day minimum you could do the extra and
all that but this is the at the fixed
times and then you would pay that poor
dude the tax the tax of your wealth
that's been sitting accumulating and now
after a year 2.5 give it to the homeless
give it to the needy that's their right
upon you that we have to you know what's
interesting if every every human being
was to pay this tax uh poverty would be
eradicated
and then the then Ramadan fasting during
the month of Ramadan and then the
pilgrimage to the first house of worship
built by Abraham like we talked about
the Hajj that's it brother that's it
yeah straightforward
minus Ramadan minus Mecca I mean I I
naturally kind of already do all that I
do fast but it's not um for an entire
month I mean you know right now I'm sure
I'm sure you know you know how how
trending now the intermittent fasting is
and a lot of Health uh gurus coming out
talking about fasting and whatnot so
we've been doing that before all the
trends
yeah
so any questions on that
no not really I mean definitely after
the show if you have any like
recommended like script or what
scriptures or verses verses yeah yes
like I shared one yeah okay yeah
definitely definitely we'll be in touch
and I'd like to answer any questions if
you hand down the line absolutely and
we're ready when you're ready to uh you
know take your shahada to come in it
seems like you're there you know what I
mean you're you're there you know yeah
I'm getting there yeah and don't and I
want to just just remind you because
there's a another verse in the Quran
where God Almighty Allah is saying and
look the only reason I repeat this in
Arabic is because to stress I'm not Arab
my family's from Bosnia but every Muslim
is inspiring to memorize some of the
Quran and then we have millions who
memorize the whole Quran so when I say
you know this is a verse from the Quran
that you will actually learn some Arabic
when you're when you start inshallah
praying uh but this is saying every soul
will taste death all of us and then you
the truly successful person is the one
who is pushed far away from the Hellfire
and admitted to the paradise and the
life of this world is nothing but a
delusion of entertainment and whatnot
but the but the truly successful one is
the one who submits to the Creator you
know so yeah so this is this is um the
call to All Humans is to turn their life
sincerely to the one God to the one
Creator God Almighty Allah to do your
best to strive for what's
forever ever not for the for the and
then to get your share of this life as
long as it's Halal as we say yeah
yeah and that's there's nothing wrong
with that
any questions
no I I definitely after the show I'm
gonna do my obviously my own research
like the law Haram and all that uh yeah
because I already know some of the stuff
but still a beginner so that's that's
the thing I wanted why I quoted this
verse is never think that we have as
much time as we want because deaf if you
go to the graveyard you can see the 16
year old the nine-year-old you can see
the 30 year old deaf is something that
can creep up at any time and we want to
be prepared we want to have the right
faith we want to have we want to be in a
state of submission to God otherwise we
don't want to lose the opportunity
because when the test we believe this
life is a test and now when the
professor says time is over you can't go
back and say can I do it
now no you had your time slot yeah so so
that's the thing that we we just kind of
create this urgency you know this kind
of where people because that's where
shaytan comes in and say oh you got time
you can you know had uh think about this
when you're older you don't know if
you're going to reach old age
100 yeah
so let's get into this uh Dylan yeah
let's get into this story so earlier
today some documents were released that
were text messages from the two supposed
victims that came out one was the
moldovan that we've already covered in
the American and if you look over those
text messages you could see how not only
did they plot to frame the tape Brothers
they rehearsed it going over what to say
how to look how to cry and how to play
Dom they even made a joke two days
before the raid happened how their
performance deserved an Oscar that they
were going to get a Netflix documentary
out of all of this things such as and I
quote such a great actress to which the
other girl said I practiced quote
unquote their performance was so good
that even their own parents called the
U.S embassy and were freaking out and
the girls got upset with their parents
because they almost messed up the show
and they admitted that they were
actually kidnapped that the tape
Brothers said that they could leave
whenever they wanted so it seems that
while the mainstream media and the
police are saying that the tape Brothers
use the Loverboy method actually what
happened was these girls girls acted as
if they were in love with the tape
brother so that they could secretly milk
it and get as much money and influence
and have people talking about them as
they could so my question is this how
long have the police had access to these
documents I mean they were already
wiretapping the tape Brothers for the
past 10 months for 10 months the police
have tried to bury the CCTV footage that
proves the tape Brothers innocence and
yes I know what you're thinking these
text messages have already been verified
they're 100 true but hey I don't want to
just tell you I want you to actually go
and see it for yourself check out the
article come to your own conclusion use
your own two eyes and use your own mind
the Tate Brothers have been framed
there's a news story unfolding that the
mainstream media seems to be silent on
it's on the what I call the two
underwear wear wearing in public uh I
don't know if they're strippers uh the
US and the UK girl evidence is coming
out that they plotted and planned a
setup they literally acted as if they
were in love with the the brothers they
apply what I would say they they applied
the this lover girl method the text text
showing them plotting to frame the
brothers uh you also talk about how they
schemed on what to say the lot how to
lie how to cry you know they bragged
about is it true winning an Oscar
performance to get on Netflix
uh and the question is uh will the
Romanian prosecutors uh prosecute what
we say these two shaytans yeah they are
shaitan for sure I mean
we'll see brother I mean they're legally
I can't talk about certain things are
going on but obviously anything I've put
out publicly I can I can go into that in
great detail but we've got two young men
Andrew Kate trusted Tate for 10 months
they were wiretapped like all their
phone calls or text messages emails they
took all their computers they were
analyzing that they got new computers
but they were wiretapped for 10 months
the I think it's called d-cott basically
to simplify for the viewers it's the
police the police for Romania
grab the CCT uh footage which clearly
showed that these women were not victims
you could see them going out getting in
cars leaving uh going getting pizza
there's some of it's still out there uh
but essentially they tried to destroy it
get rid of it they won't include it in
any of the Court like whenever you're
sitting down the court they won't
include it as evidence not it's that's
not we don't need that that's that's not
useful uh but then add to that now we've
got these text messages that have come
out and they've been verified because I
was I was like uh maybe maybe that's
just like a coincidence or something but
we've had it verified it's 100 real of
them literally plotting leading up to
two days before the raid exactly what
they were going to do step by step by
step and like they were joking around
how they were going to be uh oh you're
such a great actress we're going to get
a an Oscar we're gonna do this we're
going to do that and then whenever the
police raided the house the first time
the the they're apparently called
they're oh my God freaking out like oh
are you okay they're oh don't worry
about it Mom we're good please don't
like cause any trouble like as the
parents are trying to call the Embassy
the U.S embassy figure out what was
going on and they jokingly are saying oh
it's it's all good mom don't worry about
it we're good uh they told us we could
leave at any time and all this stuff is
there as clear as day and for me it's
Insanity we do live in the word world of
shaitan obviously so there's nah the
truth we don't we don't need that so the
media the mains for media has this
narrative they're trying to push the
human trafficking uh but then the
evidence because always the truth
prevails the truth prevailed and it's
like uh actually that wasn't true okay
let's now let's try to go over here but
the thing that frustrates me the most
about this whole thing I mean obviously
I am biased because he's a good friend
of mine but secondly there's all this
evidence out there that proves the
complete opposite and now these text
messages it literally proves that the
lover boy method happened but it was
actually lover girl they're sitting
there acting like there's serious and
all that oh okay I will come out I I
think I think you might be the one like
talking to them convincing them that
they actually cared about them they come
out there they're staying at the house
living their best life posting their
their shaitan her very Haram Tick Tock
videos and just enjoying life
and then they're actually plotting the
whole time and then and I posted this I
want to say in part three or part four
these two young women and there's lots
of evidence that shows that many girls
that were around the tape brothers were
offered money ranging from thirty
thousand to fifty thousand dollars some
cases even a hundred thousand dollars to
try to frame them but I find it funny
that these two young women and I've got
the the picture on my phone actually
these two young women went on this
French for Vera holiday which is a
pretty expensive thing flexing this
really nice watch driving a really nice
core after this they were just kidnapped
and liberated
like literally like a week or two after
the raid happened they were partying in
the French Rivera together the two girls
that were the two victims and one of
them tried to claim the UK girl the
moldovan she claimed that she was this
poor girl that he manipulated her and
all that well guess what actually that's
completely false she lived in the UK she
was a stripper she had good money and if
you and I can't go into certain details
uh but the brothers were actually
helping uh rehabilitate her from a
certain very Haram thing they were
trying to help her out and then when
they realized that she had bad
intentions they that was when they
started distancing themselves uh and
then the the American
literally land with the the ChatON in
America
she was got mad because she tried to get
a house out of the whole interaction she
she wanted him to pick by her house help
make her Tick Tock famous and all this
other stuff and he said no and actually
something I found today a follower of
mine on Twitter sent it over to me
she's this girl the American and I can
say the name out loud so it's not
docsinger it's already out there her
name's Emma Emma has a long history of
this type of stuff all the way dating
back to whenever she was 15 years old
she got mad at her mom and tried to she
just disappeared and this is literally a
recurring theme for this girl trying to
act like people are doing stuff to or
trying to like false rape things falsely
oh I've been kidnapped but it's just
because she's trying to get attention
so this pattern's continued up to these
two young women beating and plotting to
frame the Tate Brothers I don't know
their intentions behind out outside of
they just wanted attention because
obviously they wanted to have a
documentary they wanted to have their
own Netflix show they wanted the Oscar
they own all these things
uh but it's Insanity to me because if
you're wiretapping somebody for 10
months you there's no reality where you
didn't see those text messages because
they wire time anybody close to them
that's why whenever the tape brother is
this the second time
Andrew got arrested Tristan got arrested
and some other people around him got
arrested which all of them also had kids
funnily enough but oh it's okay or let's
just try to push the certain narrative
so at this point like if in my opinion
and I'm not a journalist I'm not a
lawyer I'm just a regular dude out here
on my path
at this point with these text messages
that this does not completely okay
let's we obviously don't have anything
these text messages completely disprove
everything that we've tried to build
this case over if that doesn't happen
like I'm gonna be I'm gonna be angry
because that's Insanity like if clear as
day these two victims were very
obviously they were plotting they were
rehearsing they're oh actually uh maybe
here's how you can actually look like
you're crying oh no don't say that you
need to play dumb okay yeah let's dress
up like this oh okay I'm gonna say this
and if they ask this question I want you
to say this as well they're plotting
everything and there's no way the police
didn't know it so I mean that that's my
bid on that I could talk for hours about
this I want people to understand so we
have the first thing that was a red
light where you imagine now someone
comes into your house you got cameras
all over and they come in and they steal
your stuff and now you can clearly
identify
who did it you can clear identify what
they stole but now the prosecution
doesn't want to use this case use this
uh footage for example Now flip that if
if we're understanding this correctly
you have footage of everything that's
going on in the house but the prosecutor
now is not using this they're not
allowing this into evidence they won't
even touch it okay I think they've used
aspects of it but like for the most part
don't even touch it and then this is a
career this is not you making this stuff
up this is I mean anyone can look into
this this is yeah a brother Solomon I
forgot the last name like he he does
amazing yes yes I had him on a program I
brought the salad
yes hear me like talk or whatever go
check his Twitter out he does very very
good work I've actually learned some
stuff from him just seeing his stuff on
Twitter so I was like oh wow didn't know
that so yeah I mean this stuff's
verifiable and example whenever this
whole case was beginning
they wouldn't even give the evidence to
the the law the original lawyer that we
had which we still have wouldn't even
give it to them until literally like 15
to 30 minutes before and it was a stack
of like 70 17 000 yeah 17 000 uh yeah
seventeen thousand documents documents
imagine 17 000 documents you're given
right before how can you build a defense
to that yeah these little things like
this like I started to think you know
what
there is Justice in in Romania I'm sure
they're gonna they'll get to the bottom
of this but then after what happened
yesterday and I saw those text messages
I was like okay I I I think I see the
game they're playing they're trying to
embarrass them and they've taken the the
property over there we still have
absolutely they haven't taken everything
but in Romania specifically uh they've
tried to take their cars they're trying
to humiliate them they're they've even
taken hundreds of thousands of dollars
worth of crypto I mean I and all this
stuff is documented so I'm not just
putting out inside or not all this stuff
is documented and they brag about it the
Romanian media and the government brag
about it like look what we can do so
it's not going to look good for many
many years like Romania is known for
being very corrupt but they're initially
I think they're trying to show oh we're
not corrupt but this is literally
proving that they're corrupt and if
you're a foreigner why even waste time
in a country like Romania that's very
corrupt and is going to Target you
because you have money and believe
something like these two young women
that are completely fabricated you know
it's fabricated you have all this
evidence that's fabricated but you
continue keeping these two men and
locked up in a jail cell and you're like
not allowing them to have guests like
I've tried to go other like family
members of theirs have tried to go
won't allow those little things like
this brother it's really annoying it's
really annoying so we have that one red
light here with the camera footage
number two is I want people to imagine
if you got arrested and now you're like
okay who's uh speaking out against who
are the people now that are coming up to
say I did something who are the victims
and now they got X and Y uh on the
witness sheet and you're like hold on
you know you're saying I didn't do
anything but not just that now those
victims that the cops came out they're
also protesting saying that we shouldn't
be on that list it's yeah we're not
victims so you also have that okay piece
of evidence there you also have that
that's a red light and then now we have
that you have other things but now we
have this coming out that this is the
the what's the the messages the text
messages
going in detail on the conversations of
these two strippers and I I also heard
that uh one of them or which one was
doing prostitution
was there something there with that yeah
to my knowledge that was the the girl
from the UK and then the other girl was
mainly stripper influencer yeah so you
got a stripper and a prostitute now
coming together to set up a frame job
and all the details are there and
they're bragging out how they can win an
Oscar trying to get a Netflix
documentary going
Romania what are you doing what's up and
I think we need look Dylan I think we
need some Brave congressmen to step up
to go ahead this is a U.S citizen you
know you can like him or you like him
not you know what I mean but at the end
of the day if you're out for justice you
know about certain principles you got
some Integrity now you should have some
U.S congressmen step up to go ahead and
Advocate you know based on all of this
evidence now that's con that's that's uh
for them not against them because in
Romania what we come to know is that the
prosecutor has is trying to get evidence
and now if the defense if you come up
with evidence that can exonerate them
they won't even use that
that's how their legal system that's how
they're set up I'm hearing this Romanian
attorney yeah that's crazy
yeah won't even look at it brother and
we actually we have an American lawyer
that went over there and we part of the
team was trying to get in would even
allow it so it's like little little
things like this it's going to take and
the sad part of this world now is we we
like to be divisive a lot of people
create their entire perception of
reality based off headlines so they oh
okay Andrew's uh Andrew's this this and
this so any he's just bad but
then if you just turn and look at the
truth it's very obvious that everything
that the media and everybody else is
saying it's just false so hopefully
we'll see God willing we're inshallah
inshallah yeah we will have somebody
from America that's prominent come
forward and actually start talking I've
seen he's not a politician but like
people like Tucker Carlson some other
like
Americans I guess with a an audience
have come out and been supportive but
it's gonna it's literally going to take
like some kind of American politician
that would make me gain a lot of respect
I had to come out there because these
are two American citizens being held
with zero evidence having their
properties stolen in a foreign country I
mean that sounds like something that the
U.S should actually care about yeah this
sets the president's for some what
someone else in American U.S citizen
comes up you know Americans U.S citizen
has rights now we need to go ahead and
protect these rights and you can see
they're being violated like him or like
him not if if it if he did a crime if he
did something wrong okay show the
evidence take care of what you got to
take care of but now you have all this
stuff coming out you got two stripper
and a prostitute trying to women any I
mean award an Oscar I mean come on is
that right now bragging about it I mean
come on enough is enough so action items
Dylan I mean we can give the people
start calling your uh what do you think
they can start calling some of their
local congressmen put some pressure put
some pressure on these politicians and
let's see if someone who has some
cojones they call it you know some Brave
politician Congressman whoever can come
up and start to go ahead and Advocate on
on the U.S citizens behalf what do you
think yeah 100 brother I'd say do that I
mean social media has been powerful but
if we truly truly are in alignment with
the truth in alignment with God and like
we see that this is clearly not a good
thing like that we can see the evidence
clear as day and use your own two eyes
use your own mind I'm not telling you
what to do what to believe go go look at
it yourself but the evidence is clear
that they've been framed call your local
Congressman call even call the Embassy
call the Embassy try like just beef them
beef them and just put it out there
because unless we actually do something
we were talking about earlier you can't
just talk about it you've got to
actually show it if you actually if you
actually care about the truth you need
to go out there and show it in the real
world you need to go out there call your
like you're saying your local
congressman
Embassy I mean literally anything
anything and everybody and we'll see if
anybody actually has the cajonas I think
you said to like stand up and actually
be like okay maybe I don't like this guy
maybe I don't like the lifestyle but I I
Stand For America I stand for truth and
these are two obviously innocent young
young men so I'm going to stand up and
I'm going to do something about it so
we'll see we'll see
uh Dylan thank you very much uh for
coming on and uh we'll be in touch get
uh let's uh keep uh in contact and we
can help you along your journey and all
along your way and hopefully next time
while we speak our uh Andrew tank
Christian uh Tristan Tate will be out of
this uh dungeon and um they'll be out uh
as I believe they're being held hostage
now so in Charlotte they'll be set free
thank you brother for having me thank
you very much assalamu alaikum peace be
with you thank you too I cannot leave
without giving you a gift if you are not
yet Muslim and you're tuning in to see
what these Muslims are talking about and
you like a free copy of the Quran go and
visit thedenshow.com we'll take care of
the postage and everything and get it
delivered to you and if you still have
some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you and if you
like this episode of the dean show like
this video
share this video far and wide brothers
and sisters we've all had love